the administration is also dealing with
the public relations mess tonight
involving immigrant children officials
insist reports that nearly 1,500 kids
are lost art is not true chief national
correspondent ed Henry looks at the
facts tonight when Ivanka Trump posted
this photo with her young son this
weekend that Trump haters got triggered
unleashing online attacks charging she
does not care about migrant kids and
demanding to know where are the children
a reference to allegations that over
1400 migrant children have gone missing
and blamed President Trump for ordering
they be separated from their illegal
immigrant parents even the White House
spokesman Hogan Gidley
and officials at the Department of
Health and Human Services fired back
today none of those charges are true
that is an inaccurate characterization
of what happened this month Attorney
General Jeff Sessions traveled to Texas
to announce a new policy the government
will try to prosecute everyone who
crosses the southwest border illegally
even those seeking asylum that will lead
to some parents being separated from
their children which is already part of
existing law if you are smuggling a
child then we will prosecute you and
that child may be separated from you as
required by law the fourteen hundred and
seventy five kids who allegedly went
missing arrived at the border from
October to December 2017 months before
the sessions policy went into effect
secondly HHS officials point out those
kids were part of a total of seven
thousand six hundred and thirty five
children they surveyed over those three
months who showed up at the border
without parents so they were not
separated from them Trump administration
officials took the extra step of placing
the over 7,000 kids with adult sponsors
in the u.s. HHS found six thousand and
seventy five of the kids still living
with sponsors 52 living with someone
else
28 had run away five were deported
leaving 1475 unaccounted for HHS
officials say some of their sponsors are
here illegally and likely dodging the
government's attempts to contact them
eric Horgan the HHS official
in charge of the program stating quote
the assertion that unaccompanied alien
children are lost is completely false
this is a classic example of the adage
no good deed goes unpunished that did
not stop former Obama officials like Jon
Favreau and journalists like hadass
Gould of CNN from compounding the
mischaracterizations tweeting this photo
from a-z central.com a website
affiliated with USA Today of Latino
children being held in cages to claim it
shows President Trump's policies or mean
the problem that image was taken in 2014
when Barack Obama was president
Republican Marco Rubio's are frequent
critic of the president but he gave him
some political cover on this one pressed
on whether the law dealing with
separating parents from kids should be
fixed Rubio told CBS the better law to
change is actually securing the border
right and thank you